literally one of my favorite things  that's ever happened on a movie paid  that me and his money Malkovich you know  the fact that he was even going to come  to do this movie the whole crew was  talking about it I mean for months we're  waiting for John Malkovich to get there  I mean it's a big deal when he finally  shows up he gets there and at that point  he's walking on water we do the first  take and John goes if you don't have my  money then you  fine and I'm sitting across the table  from him like I'm sorry what what what  did you just say you [ __ ] me  straight up we're talking like this and  suddenly the action if you don't  know my money and the crew burst into  Applause they're cheering they're like  wow amazing amazing and I'm looking at  him and I guess he sees me looking at  him and he leans across the table  because  terrible actor